holy Shih Tzu wasn't chapter one a freak
week amazing riding with grace oh it's
riding with grace because I really don't
want to write this whole thing by myself
it's riding with grace riding with me me
my name is grace if you didn't
understand that reference in the
beginning then you obviously did not
read chapter one of freak week which I
encourage you to stop this video right
now go read chapter one on Wattpad waka
calm / writing wit and then come back
and watch the rest of this episode of
writing with grace because it'll make a
lot more sense to you and be much more
enjoyable and a better use of your time
and mine if you decided to disregard all
of that and watch anyway hi welcome to
another episode of riding with grace in
which you and I are writing a novella
together called black one for those of
you that did read chapter one a freak
week thank you I know a lot of you might
have read chapter one and thought prune
grace these characters seem oddly
familiar the main character's name is
lace and her two friends in this first
chapter are Marmee and banana but I can
assure you that they are all fictional
characters and like all great artists
and comedians I did in no way draw from
my real life to create this art
I've been motorcycles in the sky but I'm
glad that you guys are enjoying it and
I'm really excited for you guys to
continue it and I know that you guys
will make all kinds of stuff happen cuz
look I've read some of your fanfic on
Wattpad and yeah a lot of stuff happens
and those fanfics you guys I thought it
might be helpful in this episode to go
over some general writing tips that I
use on a regular basis that might be
helpful for you guys throughout this
whole writing with grace process here
are Grace's writing tips for writing
with grace right now one dialogue is key
in my opinion when characters have
actual conversations with each other
it's way more interesting it's also way
more interesting to read live on stage
in a live show form like something we
will be doing at VidCon at the end of
this entire process wink nudge elbow
sorry I thought you chew less is more
but not so much less that you just have
blank sticky notes all over your
computer screen no we are looking for
your writing submissions to be about
1500 words try not to exceed that
because I like reading but you know I'm
also a human three have fun everyone has
their own unique style of writing that
feels authentic to them so make sure
you're expressing that if you forget any
of those helpful tips just use the
acronym dick limb to jog your memory
I've used it for years
dickham rolls off the tongue it comes
out of the top area of your mouth when
you say it which is unique dick now
those are all my tips for this process
but here are some actual rules that you
guys should really abide by because
otherwise we won't be able to read your
submission no swearing
I know right you cannot use celebrities
or brand name sorry guys trust me I had
some really great jokes in this first
chapter that I had to say goodbye with
them and make sure that you are using
the hashtag writing with grace because
the easiest way for this idiot
to find all of your submissions please I
need it excuse me
also look I know Wattpad is a breeding
ground of all your filthy Phil is a
beautiful fanfic and look I read a lot
of it
but we got to keep it kind of clean here
okay imagine that you are reading your
submission out loud to your dad and no
not drew Monson and I know he's
everybody's daddy but to your actual
father keep it fluffy guys that's a fan
fixed-term and you're right I used it
don't use I just broke my own rule I'm
allowed to okay now on to chapter 2
which comes from you you know just word
to the wise I don't love rhyming so you
could avoid that in new chapters of
beautiful but you know you do you I'm
sorry
it also rhymes you need to describe
crush laces crush in Chapter one is
named crush but that's all we know so
give that character character what do
they talk what do they like are they
human there are so many opportunities
here get creative get weird get wild get
within the rules and regulations of this
series as well please also chapter two a
brief week is day two of freak week
which means a brand new environmental
shift and possibly some emotional ships
it's up to you let us know go forth and
do it
but thank you guys again for reading
chapter 1 this is so fun and now I'm
extra excited because the gates are open
I'm excited to go over all of my
favorite moments and my favorite authors
that I find along the way because you
know how the internet stalking works if
I go to your Wattpad page it might not
stop there so nothing is off-limits guys
other than the limit other than the
actual limits that are within this whole
writing process
here's another curveball because I just
I don't know how to throw a baseball
straight we're taking next week off but
don't worry don't see that Shh
we'll be back the week after that's it
this is so exciting
you guys have until Sunday night post
your chapter two's on Wattpad using the
hashtag writing with grace so I can find
it easily
please forget about your homework that
you should do to become a better student
forget about your hobbies that you
should engage in to become a better
human being everything else is secondary
even your armpits sharing come home oh
even shower showering is always you
tearing everything else can wait are you
pregnant
wait are you in the middle of a breakup
wait are you lifting weights right now
wait I remember guys no smut but all the
fluff I'll see you guys next week I
can't wait to read but you're crazy
filthy dirty beautiful minds come up
with I don't know